oh
I love that smell makes me hungry when I
when I smell it hello hello do you make
salads yeah yeah I'll do a frozen Bowl
yeah that works can I do uh turkey only
turkey can you give me triple meat Just
Turkey perfect it's like a buffet
protein I might just eat this for dinner
is that triple meat that's three yeah no
not a lot can I go four let's go
four meat portions it's light just
lettuce and then banana peppers we can
throw some Jalapenos in there too thank
you actually you can put tomatoes in
there too that'd be great yep just a few
nope no sauce actually the first time I
saw this where it looks like it's full
of cookies because of the sheet I
thought that was really clever it gives
the feel of inventory
thank you 45 grams of protein and 400
calories